this one's
really bad hey everyone i'm abby sharp
welcome to abby's
[Music]
kitchen today's video is sponsored by
builtbar and we'll be taking a look at
youtuber and self-titled professional
eater eric the electric but first let me
tell you about my sponsor billbar we're
definitely getting close to the holidays
and that to me means that things are
going to be getting busier and busier
around here having some easy snacks on
hand will be key for the days that i'm
you know traveling around to see family
or running errands so billbar has been
one of my go-to's for a while now and i
really usually don't love protein bars
but these babies taste like actual
chocolate bars because they're made with
real chocolate while of course packing a
ton of protein and not tasting like
chalk so i like that let's take a little
tasty taste
what are we gonna get into today
well i think we're gonna go with like a
classic chocolate all the chocolate
double chocolate
17 grams of protein worth of chocolate
can i get an amen what what
[Music]
pop it up
nothing makes your girl dance better
than a little double chocolate on a
friday but anyways this is of course a
lower sugar option for those looking for
that so i personally love to put mine on
top of my oatmeal breakfast or like
serve with some ice cream for dessert
before bed it's honestly so good so if
you want to give this a try check out my
link in the description and use my promo
code abbysharp15 to get 15 off of your
purchase now before we get into it feel
free to pause the screen or look at the
description to check out my disclaimer
including a major major major trigger
warning to those with current or
previous experiences with distorted
eating i'm gonna be talking explicitly
about eating disorder related topics in
this video so of course as always feel
free to skip this video if it's not
supportive to your journey also if you
are new here welcome don't forget to
subscribe to this channel and ring that
bell so that you never miss out all
righty then
all righty then for starters a little
backgrounder on our pal era eric is a
popular youtuber who's amassed 1.6
million subscribers thanks to the
popularity of his food challenge videos
now some of his most popular videos
include calorie challenges where he eats
anywhere between fifteen thousand to a
hundred thousand calories in a day a
mukbang style i mean it's pretty intense
stuff but interestingly eric has been
quite candid about his previous history
with anorexia and now credits food
challenges and competitive eating as a
tool that he used to confront his fear
of food and that sounds a little similar
to you know some other folks that we've
reviewed on the channel before like
always hungry and nicocado avocado now
we're going to be talking more about the
nuances of this later on in the video
but for now let's focus on what eric
eats on a normal day when he's not doing
one of his big food challenges and fyi
to make this as up to date as possible i
actually found this one on his instagram
let's take a look
[Music]
okay let's get into this um in the
morning eric has one black coffee and
has some pre-workout
it doesn't actually provide very much
besides maybe some caffeine hydration
and some b vitamins and while the
caffeine in the coffee and in the
pre-workout may give them a good energy
boost to help power him through that 50
mile bike ride i would still definitely
want to be seeing more caloric fuel in
the tank to help support his endurance
needs so fasted cardio for recreational
fitness enthusiasts is one thing but
he's going all night without fuel and
then doing a solid two and a half hours
on the bike so yeah he's almost
definitely blowing through those
glycogen stores and potentially eating
into metabolic muscle one recent review
of the literature suggested that
endurance athletes should avoid high
intensity activity while in a fasted
state as it can increase the risk of low
blood sugar dehydration dizziness and of
course in worst cases passing out so i
would definitely recommend a pre-workout
meal with protein and a solid amount of
fast-acting carbs in there something
like a fruit-based shake with a little
bit of yogurt in it would be an easily
digested option
[Music]
okay so
most people don't need a sports drink
after working out but i would say that
this is definitely a scenario where i
think it's indicated to help rehydrate
and replenish those electrolytes
[Music]
h2o but it's equally important to be
replenishing those energy stores and
protein to help support post-workout
recovery ideally after two intense
back-to-back workouts like this
especially considered they were done
fasted we would want a solid meal in
here with a ratio of 1 gram of protein
to about 4 grams of carbs as the name
suggests poweraid zero provides zero
protein zero carbs and zero calories so
if maintaining that metabolic muscle is
eric's goal this is definitely not an
ideal plan and i'm being pretty damn
generous with that comment
okay so it's 7 p.m and we finally get to
see some real food i guess better light
than ever but here we're getting some
much needed protein from the steak and
whatever fish is likely in the sushi
we've got some carbs in the sushi rice
and sweet potato and hopefully some fat
in that salad dressing so while we are
hitting the hunger crushing combo here
it's no shocker that this meal is pretty
high volume and high calorie but i would
say that we definitely need those
calories and honestly a lot more
considering his workout alone likely
burned almost 3 000 calories i just
finished one of the most intense
workouts i've done for a while it's
really no question that this amount of
energy expenditure would spark up some
pretty ravenous hunger but is this the
best time for this big meal and
subsequent snack no no it's not it seems
like we're playing a little bit of kind
of catch up on our caloric and protein
intake here which brings me to the oh so
important topic of meal and protein
timing we now know through recent
research that the anabolic protein
window for muscle protein synthesis is
actually much wider than we once thought
it's actually around four hours around
the training session now since eric had
a fasted workout so nothing since the
night before
we actually have a much shorter window
to work with here so we would want to
see that meal within the first hour
after training not six hours later it's
also better to have multiple protein
doses throughout the day instead of
having all of it all at once at the end
of the day because for athletes like
eric the body can only use up to about
0.25 to 0.4 grams of protein per
kilogram of body weight for muscle
protein synthesis every three to four
hours depending on which equation we're
going to use based on which study you
want to cite we're looking at somewhere
between 1.2 to 2 grams of protein per
kilogram of body weight or about 20 to
30 grams of protein per sitting in four
to six doses per day i know
i know your girl is getting technical as
in simpler terms if eric really insisted
on doing fasted cardio for whatever
reason i would want to move this protein
bar immediately after his cycling
session along with maybe a couple pieces
of fruit or toast since this bar is just
a one-to-one ratio of carbs to protein
and then i'd want to have the steak meal
like a few hours after that
so in another one of eric's videos he
discusses his supplement regimen which
includes a pretty varied cocktail of
supplements including iron and collagen
to help support his muscles and athletic
performance selenium for his thyroid
coq10 for energy and vitamin d for
immunity those are his words not mine
now eric also says that he often tries
to hack his high calorie food challenges
by taking a probiotic to help combat the
bad bacteria from the types of foods
that he eats in all his videos along
with a fish oil supplement to counteract
the inflammation and brain fog brought
on by said foods now lastly eric also
takes a berberine supplement to help
manage the so-called blood sugar spikes
that he experiences post-food challenges
uh
i just want to say
you know what is an actual
evidence-based hack for combating all of
these not so pleasant health outcomes
not doing these challenges in the first
place like
i don't get it i am all for supplements
especially for specific health
conditions if they help improve your
quality of life and allow for some more
flexibility in your diet but with all of
those horrible uncomfortable side
effects i don't know how these
challenges would positively contribute
to
quality of life it seems like this guy
is just bouncing from one uncomfortable
extreme to the next which i'm going to
talk about more in just a minute but i
can't imagine that any supplement is
going to completely eliminate or improve
outcomes better than like prioritizing
consistent nutrient dense meals anyways
let's see how he ends the night
[Music]
okay so about an hour after his protein
bar and steak salad eric has two
substantial bowls of lucky charm cereal
plus a bowl of fruit some rice cakes and
some peanut butter now i have no issue
with these foods i think that they can
all fit into a balanced diet right here
for example we are getting some protein
and fat from the milk and the peanut
butter and some carbs from the cereal
fruit and rice cakes and as i
demonstrated in my hunger crushing combo
video right here sugary cereal like
lucky charms can absolutely
be incorporated and turned into balanced
snacks but the fact that he's eating
over like a thousand calories of
predominantly refined carbohydrates all
within the same hour feels
a bit chaotic like it's almost like his
body and mind is begging to be caught up
to meet their needs and he has to pull
like a cinderella before the clock
strikes 12 and the restriction starts
all over again now i'm absolutely not
diagnosing eric or anyone else but this
is textbook binge restrict cycle
behavior and it's especially concerning
to me given eric's eating disorder
history now before i dive deeper into
that i do want to talk about my overall
thoughts on eric's diet based on our
rough calculations on this particular
day eric's eating roughly 2 200 calories
within a short three hour window now
this is actually substantially more than
what we have seen in some of his other
videos where he's only eating like 400
calories of chicken rice and lettuce
between those food challenge days either
way it's not enough for the level of
activity he's doing on a day like this
he would actually likely need between 3
000 and 5 000 calories and consistently
like not an erratic cycle of extreme
over consumption and under consumption
sure modest caloric fluctuations from
day to day are absolutely normal and can
be easily accommodated by the body but
eating 10 000 calories one day and then
400 calories for three days will not net
out the same in the body as consuming
2800 calories consistently for four days
our energy levels will suffer our
metabolism will suffer our muscles will
suffer our digestion will suffer our
body needs adequate and consistent
nutrition to function at its best not
once a week not some of the time not
three hours a day every day
2 800 calories
the shell has spoken no amount of
caloric restriction intense exercise or
supplement hacks are going to be able to
effectively undo the damage from this
lifestyle as for his protein intake
eric's consuming about 93 grams of
protein on this day which is considered
on the low end of what's acceptable for
an athlete depending on which standards
you use obviously on other
non-competitive days when he's just kind
of getting the one meal of chicken and
rice a day it's not sufficient but even
if he does get this 90 grams a day
consistently it's not being optimally
utilized by his super active and
probably starving muscles not only
because there's a significant delay
between training and protein intake but
also because he's not spacing out his
protein intake throughout the day so if
we spaced out eric's protein and
calories throughout the day in more
equal doses aka meals we would
definitely see better muscle protein
synthesis better appetite regulation
better digestion and also probably
better sleep because i don't know i
can't imagine it feels very good to
marathon eat 3 000 calories right before
bed now i alluded to some of this
earlier but i want to chat about some of
the physical and psychological concerns
i have about eric's erratic pattern of
eating starting of course with some
physical concerns now when somebody
overeats to the extent that eric does in
his food challenges it can be seriously
taxing on the digestive system not only
can it cause significant stomach
stretching as eric himself will often
demonstrate in his videos
there's a
quite a food baby
no i'm not perfect but it also puts
excessive metabolic strain on the liver
pancreas and intestines as these organs
now have to kick into overdrive to
digest and absorb such a large quantity
of food not to mention it can cause some
pretty uncomfortable short-term side
effects like acid reflux gas abdominal
discomfort bloating water retention and
fatigue the same can be said about
plowing through so much cereal right
before bed every single night after a
full day of over exercising and fasting
now eric insists that he has the unique
ability to handle this stuff as his
perfect blood work would suggest and as
my colleague eric williamson told me
when i consulted him on this case it is
true that for healthy individuals
consuming a one-off carb-heavy meal
shouldn't have any major impacts on
blood sugar levels since blood glucose
is pretty tightly controlled in an
individual that doesn't have diabetes
but as amazingly resilient as our bodies
can be to these brief periods of
inconsistent nutrition with enough wear
and tear we can start to see the
long-term impact so we're talking about
things like poor metabolic functioning
and an increased risk of diabetes heart
disease osteoporosis gi dysfunction
hormonal imbalance vitamin deficiencies
and more and these physical health risks
are honestly the least of my concern
there are also some major psychological
concerns with eric's lifestyle first we
do know that excessive intake of
ultra-processed fast foods have been
associated with an increased risk of
depression and can negatively impact gut
bacteria as actually he mentioned
himself now research also suggests that
a high-fat nutrient-poor diet can
increase feelings of irritability
aggression impact attention memory and
mood and also negatively affect our
ability to emotionally regulate i
honestly wouldn't be too concerned about
this if the lion's share of eric's
weekly meals were nutrient dense
well-balanced and adequately spaced for
optimal hormonal levels but based on the
information that we've gathered even in
this kind of off day that doesn't appear
to be the case even more importantly to
me is the risk to his psychological
well-being and relationship with food
now first i want to start by saying that
again i'm not here to diagnose or imply
that eric has an eating disorder if he
says that the food challenges have
helped him to heal his food fear and he
is happier and healthier for it then i
will leave it to him and hopefully a
therapist or professional to unpack that
experience what i can say is that
research does support food exposure and
habituation as an effective treatment
strategy to help normalize fear foods
but and this is a big but
engaging in extreme food challenges is
absolutely not how any eating disorder
recovery protocol would look what we're
seeing here is essentially a pendulum
swinging between extreme caloric
restriction and compensatory excessive
exercise to extreme binge eating all
under the guise of combating fear foods
for entertainment purposes now eric
himself has been quoted to say that he
doesn't consider what he does to be
healthy and that what he does would
probably be clinically classified as an
eating disorder like i said i'm not here
to diagnose eric so those are his words
not mine but if we were to look
objectively at the diagnostic criteria
for bulimia nervosa non-purge subtype in
the dsm-5 it would be characterized as
frequently eating large amounts of food
in a short period at least once a week
while simultaneously compensating with
excessive exercise to prevent weight
gain again i'm not making a diagnosis
but for strictly educational purposes i
do want to point out that it's not
abnormal for individuals with previous
histories of eating disorders to
essentially swap eds it's also a very
common disordered eating pattern to
essentially restrict heavily all day and
then consume all of your calories at the
end of the day almost as an act of
extreme delayed gratification i know
when i was struggling with my eating
disorder i actually did exactly that i
would basically eat the bare minimum to
survive all day while distracting myself
from eating with excessive exercise and
then by dinner i would just go from one
snack to the next until i fell asleep
going to bed often becomes the only way
to get oneself to halt the binge train
because once you open those floodgates
it feels like your starved body and mind
won't let you stop now whether or not
this is the case for eric i do not know
and i'm not suggesting that it is but my
concern is that people with previous ed
histories who watch his videos may get
the message that extreme mukbang style
eating challenges may be a good recovery
strategy because they see that eric
looks to be weight restored or he seems
to be at peace eating a big bowl of
lucky charms every night okay or
multiple bowls that is not true recovery
at least not for most people true
recovery would be nourishing your body
every day all day allowing yourself
lucky charms when you want them along
with other foods that make you feel good
not consistently eating so many bowls of
lucky charms that you feel sick and not
punishing yourself with restriction the
next day because you ate said extra
bowls of lucky charm i know it's so easy
to justify this behavior as food freedom
because that's what my eating disorder
voice told me too but there is a much
better way and it starts with quitting
the food challenges and other extreme
diet plans that require some form of
compensatory mechanisms or behaviors and
instead learning what actually feels
good to your body all day every day for
the rest of your life and on that note
that is all that i have for you guys
today a big reminder to please be kind
in the comments and another thank you to
buildbar for sponsoring this video if
you liked it be sure to give it the
thumbs up leave me a comment below on
who you'd like to see me review next
subscribe to this channel and i will see
you next time bye